[Music]
more than four million books worldwide
her first 12 novels in the Chief
Inspector Gamache series have been
published in 30 countries translated
into 25 languages this girl is good
Vinny's latest book is called Glass
Houses
it takes readers back to the fictional
Canadian village of Three Pines a
mysterious figure appears on the village
green and then don't dump dump dump dump
dump dump
that's right Bill trouble follows
we welcome Louise Benny to the table
good morning Louise anymore I love when
she sat down she said Nora I loved your
golf segment Nora said you play golf yes
I was just golfing with President
Clinton Bill Clinton ah that's pretty
nice pretty nice company okay let's talk
about this book what I think is so
fascinating about the inspector years
ago when you started writing about him
you said I want to write about a guy I
would like to marry and the qualities of
that what does that mean well when I
first started designing this series I
didn't actually think I want it to be
published yeah I didn't actually believe
it would because it's hard so I knew
that the writing of it would probably
have to be reward enough because it may
be the only reward I would get so I
created a village I would live in Three
Pines populated with characters I would
choose his friends and then it came time
to create the main character and
initially I thought well I'll make him a
man at odds with himself maybe a some
sort of a addict of some sort and
unhappy fellow and then I thought I'm
god I'm finally God why would I create
that I had also heard that Agatha
Christie and I don't know if this is
true uh-huh
I had grown weary of Poirot her main
character I always thought that was sad
that the whole world loved this
character except his mother and I
thought again if I'm lucky and I become
connected to this character I don't want
to get tired of him so I thought he has
to be a man I would marry and then
Michel enters your life your husband
yeah Cheers whoo you lost recently and
you said that writing glass houses
became a solace for you it did because
Michael actually was the inspiration for
Inspector Gamache it not only did I
create a man I would marry I actually
did marry yeah Michael was diagnosed
with dementia three or four years ago
and when I started writing these books
shortly after 9/11 I thought that it
would create a saw a safe place for
people who were feeling unsafe in the
world as I was and I get letters from
readers saying that reading the books is
comforting for them which means a lot to
me I never ever dreamed that I would
find so much comfort in writing the
books as Michael was dying
and I thought honestly I thought once
Michael went I wouldn't be able to write
anymore because he was my news he was
the champion exact the cheerleader he
was ganache but in fact the opposite has
happened and Gamache is so infused with
my husband that it it has made him in
many ways immortal you write to that
murder is a way to explore human nature
yeah well I think we're Nevermore
ourselves than when we are pushed it's
easy to be a decent human being when
everything is going my way but what
happens when it's not and that's when we
see true character come out this is
interesting that's what I wanted to know
thank God really yeah if there wasn't I
love your origin story as a novelist
because used to have this gig right CBC
broadcaster radio and and decided I'm
gonna write the perfect novel five years
later thank you had nothing come home
and said I wasn't writing going and then
touch the TV you've been watching Oprah
Oprah and eating gummy bears it came to
the point where Michael stopped asking
you know you're in trouble because this
ain't going on your thing going no it
was like when I reached 35 and my mass
stopped asking me if I'd met any nice
men yes
what broke you through them and and what
advice do you have for a couple of
things it I noticed that in in my life
when horrible things happen they seem
happen out of the blue but in fact they
don't it's it's a it's a cavalcade of
smaller events the same with this great
thing Michael and I moved out of the
city into the country this book is set
in the country I fell in with a bunch of
very creative women who were who were
courageous who had the courage to do
what I didn't and that was to risk
failing yeah I didn't want to fail
that's why I thought it had to be the
best book out of the out of the gate and
if I couldn't do that I was frozen well
there's a lot of food in the book too
which made me hungry and made me think
you must be a good cook I'm not I am a
great either me too Louise penny
congratulations on number 13 right lucky
for the Train Glass Houses is on sale
next Tuesday